For today.
We have the honor of speaking with Dr Jeannie Psi,
um,
about the question regarding to what extent are emotions culturally shaped?
Dr Sigh received her phd in clinical psychology from the University of
California Berkeley and did her clinical internship and post doctoral fellowship
in minority mental health at the University of California San Francisco.
She's currently an associate professor of psychology at Stanford University and
director of the culture and emotion lab.
Dr. Size research focuses on how cultural ideas and practices shape our
feelings,
identities,
and even mental health.
She's highly regarded,
especially for her work that we discussed today on an affect valuation across
cultures.
She's received numerous awards including a young investigator award from the
National Alliance for research on schizophrenia and depression and early career
award for distinguished contributions from the Asian American Psychological
Association and the Dean's Award for distinguished teaching from Stanford
University.
So I now turn to a very special experts and emotion interview with Doctor Janie
Sy.
So welcome jeany.
Thanks for coming today and speaking.
Oh,
it's my pleasure.
Thanks June.
So what I often like to ask people to sort of start his tasks in a little bit
about where you first started in the study of emotion,
kind of how did it all begin for you?
Well,
um,
I was an Undergrad here at Stanford and I was starting to take psychology
classes because I was really interested in human behavior and understanding why
people do the things they do.
And when I started taking the psychology classes,
it became really clear to me that a lot of the models of human behavior that I
was learning in class really didn't apply to my experience as,
you know,
the child of Taiwanese immigrants.
And so,
and,
and one of the examples that I thought was the most surprising was descriptions
of East Asians and particularly Chinese as stoic and inscrutable and is not
having any emotion because my family was so emotional.
And um,
yeah.
So when I was applying to graduate school,
that's Bob Levenson at the University of California,
Berkeley was just starting to write a grant on ethnicity to emotion.
And it just seemed like a really good place to start because you know,
emotions do,
you have this universal quality to them and we think that we can really read the
emotions of other people and it's really what unites us.
And yet at the same time we talk a lot about cultural differences and there
wasn't really that much research on culture and emotion.
Most of it was ethnographic and so it seemed like a really good place to start.
So that's why I was trying to look on motion.
I mean,
so since then you've really paved the way for how we think about the way that
culture does shape emotional responding and especially,
I mean you're wide known from your groundbreaking research and understanding the
link between culture and emotion through your theory,
looking at athletic valuation and wonder if you could tell us
a little bit about the fundamental principles of what Aflac valuation is and how
it shapes emotional responding cross culturally.
Yeah,
sure.
Well with theory,
athlete valuation theory really came from the work on culture and emotion that I
was doing with Bob Levinson.
And then later with my graduate students where we were really trying to
understand how culture influences how we respond to different emotional events.
And um,
there at the time there wasn't really any debate that if you had some sort of
event that meant something different across cultures,
then you'd have a different emotional response.
But the question at the time was,
if you had an event that meant the same thing,
would you see differences in physiology and paving subjective experience.
And what we found,
um,
you know,
study after study was that there were more cultural similarities than
differences.
And I was really surprised by that.
Wow.
And,
but it really made me start thinking that maybe,
um,
what,
what was differing across cultures was more how people want it to feel,
what we call their ideal ethic more than how they actually felt,
where their actual effect.
So ethic valuation theory was really a way of trying to incorporate that insight
and um,
ideal ethic into current models of emotion,
which really focused on actual effect.
And so the first premise is really just that how we want to feel are ideal
athletic differs from how we actually feel our actual ethics.
And that might seem like really obvious,
but what's surprising is,
as you know in psychology,
most of it is search is really focused on actual ethic.
And so we just created measures of self report measures will,
where we asked people how much do you actually feel these states on average,
and how much you want to feel these states on average.
And we find across a variety of different cultures that people consistently
report wanting to feel more positive and less negative than they actually feel.
And when we use much more complicated statistics,
again,
we sort of find that there are these differences between actual and ideal
aspect.
So this sort of sad story is that even though there are some times where you
feel how you really want to feel,
most of the time you don't.
Um,
so that's the first premise.
And then that distinction really matters when it comes to thinking about how
culture influences how we feel.
Because the second premise is that although culture influences how we want to
feel and how we actually feel,
it influences how we want to feel even more than how we actually feel.
And again,
we've done lots of studies that have shown this using a variety of methods.
When we use self report methods or um,
or behavioral methods,
we find that the cultural differences are larger for how people want to feel
than how they actually feel.
And most of those studies are comparing European American and Chinese,
um,
samples.
And what we find is it your Americans really value excitement,
enthusiasm because these high arousal positive states,
um,
more than in Chinese culture where there's more of an emphasis on,
low arousal,
positive states,
calm,
peacefulness and serenity and these cultural differences in ideal athletic
emerge even when you control for differences in actual effect.
And oftentimes we don't find any differences in how much people actually feel
these states really more and how they want to feel a states.
Um,
so we've also done studies where we look at widely distributed cultural products
like magazine advertisements or children's storybooks.
And again,
we find that the content of these products really reflect these cultural
differences.
An ideal ethics of American magazines have more excitement,
smiles and pure comms,
miles and Chinese magazines.
Um,
we think then just comes to the third premise of ethic valuation theory.
That ideal aspect really plays an important role in our emotional lives.
And again,
it's,
this is one of these things where because most of the work on emotion really
focused on American context,
it was sort of be given that everybody wanted to feel the same way.
But by doing this cultural analysis,
it really revealed that people actually vary within and across cultures and how
they want to feel and that this plays itself out and what people do to feel good
whether you decide to go bungee jumping to go to yoga class or meditate.
Um,
so we,
so we find that how people want to feel influences lots of different choices in
their lives.
Like what kind of music they want to listen to,
even what kinds of consumer products they use if you choose a more calm and
soothing lotion versus a more exciting and stimulating lotion.
And it also influences things like what kind of physician you want to be,
your primary care physician,
um,
and what kinds of social partners you choose.
So those are three sort of premises of ethic valuation theory.
I mean it's shapes just such a broad domain of not only I tell feeling states
and the kinds of emotions that people gravitate towards,
but you're saying just a profound array of behaviors to in everyday life.
Right?
And that the idea that can influence these things even more than actual ethics.
It's not saying that how we actually feel doesn't influence these things.
It certainly does that ideal athletic may influence certain kinds of behaviors
even more so.
I mean you've also done this work on cultural variation across emotion response,
looking at physiology,
behavior and subjective experience of emotion.
And you alluded a little to us earlier in your original work with Bob Levenson
and I wonder if you could say a bit more about what were some of the most
exciting,
and it sounds like some surprising discoveries here when you embarked on this
multi-method approach to understanding cultural differences and emotion
responding.
Yeah,
we were really,
I mean,
I really was expecting so many more cultural differences and cultural
similarities and we would bring,
um,
European Americans and Asian Americans by Cultural Asian Parkins into the lab
and we'd have them,
we lived there for an emotional episodes and watched emotional film clips.
We had couples talk about emotional topics into the relationship.
And across these different studies we found more similarities than differences,
similarities in their physiological responses,
in the reports of subjective experience.
When we found differences,
they were in behavior.
Um,
and those behavioral differences or facial expressions,
um,
we're,
we're more pronounced in interpersonal context.
So in the couple of studies when people are actually interacting with another
person,
we found more of these differences in behavior then when they were,
you know,
watching a film by themselves.
Um,
but even those differences that we found were surprising.
So the literature up until then had suggested that Japanese smile more during
negative emotion as a way of masking or controlling their negative emotions.
So we thought maybe we would find that.
But what we found actually was that the European Americans smile more during
positive events like during happiness and then Asian Americans,
even though they reported feeling the same amount of subjective happiness.
And we now understand this as again,
another manifestation of these cultural differences in ideal,
an effect that when you come from a culture that really encourages you to feel
excited,
a lot of times behaviourally what you're doing unconsciously is amplifying your
positive emotions,
are amplifying your happiness.
And this is what we found that our European Americans were doing in these
studies of emotional responding.
So the study found more similarities than differences.
It's again,
what led to us to start thinking about cultural differences and ideal ethic.
But we do think these cultural differences and ideal ethic influenced different
aspects of response,
particularly expressive behavior.
So what you're saying is that ideal AFX sort of shapes what emotional behaviors
you amplify or show to the world,
right?
Or,
and then really unconsciously and really quickly.
So you know,
when you think of what's the most happy smile we think of the Julia Roberts
Smile,
right?
I think the big smile,
oh right.
The big plan,
that's really happiness.
And I think that really is reflection of the emphasis our culture places on
these high arousal positive states.
And again,
like when we look at,
for example,
websites,
your Facebook page,
as you can see that Asian Americans who are also and Hong Kong,
Chinese also showing happiness or showing more calm smiles,
they're not showing that Julia Roberts smile that were,
that we all love.
And there you go with your,
Julia Roberts went out.
So one of the things that's also fascinating about the work you do is it has
this really kind of beautiful translational component where you've looked at how
cultural variation and emotion responding,
you know,
maybe influenced or how it looks in individuals with symptoms of depression.
And I wonder if you could say a little bit about how different kinds of social
cultural context may shape the onset and course of this common chronic and
really debilitating disorder for many people.
You know,
um,
this is was one of the reasons I was really interested in studying emotion for
the obvious clinical implications.
And again,
you know,
there's just a lot of literature suggesting that culture influences the
expression of,
um,
a variety of emotional disorders,
but not a lot of research on how,
and what I really think is true,
and this is the anthropologists had been arguing this for a while,
but,
uh,
how we define,
um,
depression and other forms of,
and other abnormal behavior really depends on how we define what's the more
normal.
And so,
in a series of studies with Yulia 10 Sova Denton,
and we looked at the impact of depression on emotional functioning in European
Americans and Asian Americans,
and we replicated the common finding that for European Americans who are
depressed,
depressions dampens their emotional functioning,
right?
They show the splat ethic.
They're less likely to smile during an amazing film clip.
Um,
but for your,
for Asian Americans,
we actually see the opposite effect.
Asian Americans actually amplify their emotional responses when they're
depressed.
Wow.
Cry More and response to a sad film clip.
They smile more when they're,
I'm watching them using film clip.
And we think that this has to,
this really illustrates how cultural norms of emotion play a role in the
manifestation of depression.
So European Americans are probably dampening because they can't adhere to the
cultural ideal of expressing their high arousal,
positive ethic,
right?
So they depression and being depressed means they're there,
they're showing flat flattened or damp and responses.
But for Asian Americans,
their ideal really is to moderate their emotions,
to try to get to this low arousal state.
So when they can't do it,
when they're depressed,
you're actually showing a greater response.
So I think that this work really suggests that even how we assess depression,
um,
has,
has to,
we have to take into consideration the cultural ideals and practices of the
group that we're looking at.
And that depression can manifest itself differently,
looks different depending on the cultural context or the cultural norms of the
patient.
And this,
so this obviously has implications for how we assess depression.
We have some studies that show that American clinicians are more likely to call
and non-depressed Asian American depressed because at showing that excitement
that they're expecting that they're going to see in somebody who's not
depressed.
Um,
and so I,
you know,
we think that clinicians really need to take this into consideration when
they're assessing depression and even when they're treating depression.
So there's a lot of data that suggests that ethnic minorities and Asian
Americans in particular don't adhere to.
Um,
they,
they don't continue with psychotherapy and they don't adhere to a variety of
psychiatric treatments.
And in part,
that may be because the treatments that they're receiving are treatments that
are trying to get them to this high arousal positive state,
which is in a state that they actually want to feel.
So the data that I love the most,
it's sort of come from your area of expertise or the data that suggests that,
you know,
an American context.
Um,
American bipolar patients are just notorious for not wanting to take their mood
stabilizers.
And because it takes away the highs that they like.
But in Hong Kong,
the adherence rates for mood stabilizers are significantly higher.
Almost everybody takes them among the bipolar patients.
And again,
I think it's because we don't know for sure,
but my theory about it is that it's because in would stabilize mood stabilizers
are that low arousal state.
It's valued by the culture.
So culture can influence,
you know,
even whether or not you would hear two particular treatments.
That's amazing.
I mean,
in,
in the case of bipolar disorder,
I know we've been talking about this and some of the work we're doing,
I mean,
that is one of the most significant barriers to treatment is just having people
accept what the treatment target is and adhering to medications or thigh
psychotherapy that's gonna bring them down from that high arousal states.
Right?
Yeah.
So I would also suggest that maybe in therapy what we need to be doing is
changing people's aspect of ideals.
Yeah,
no.
And that maybe that's a way to get them to adhere to treatment more.
Well,
you said also made me wonder too about how we track symptom change over time.
So,
you know,
you're talking about how an Asian American cultures there can be this
amplification of even positive affectivity the more depressed they are.
So in many ways it seems that what they're manifesting is the opposite of the
kinds of changes that are tracked in your typical sort of,
you know,
western American,
uh,
you know,
treatment protocol.
We're looking for more amplified emotion expressions as a sign that depression,
you know,
being going into remission.
Right,
right.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I mean,
so as someone who's an expert in so many things in this domain from the kinds of
emotions we want to feel,
the kinds of emotions people manifest and experience coming from different
cultural context and also the way the shapes such important mental health
outcomes as depression.
Um,
when you think about what got you into motion and all the work you've done now,
he sort of turned towards the future horizon,
sort of,
where do you see the future going in emotion,
where does it,
where is it headed next in your opinion?
Well,
I think that um,
one relate same direction is that people are really assuming more of an
interdisciplinary approach to your emotion.
I mean,
they're really trying to bridge different areas.
So I think of a lot of the work that is going on,
on emotion in cancer and in lots of different kinds of health settings.
So I think that's really exciting.
We're looking at emotions in the workplace and I mean,
there's always been some of that work now,
but I think there's even more,
it's being brought into the mainstream aspect of science work.
Um,
but I think really the future has to be in,
this obviously comes from,
you know,
my interest to really think about how culture,
our cultural ideas and practices shape how we do the science of emotion.
And you know,
what our assumptions are about emotion.
Because if we really want to study human emotion,
we really have to think about our socio cultural context.
I mean everybody is shaped by their,
the dominant cultural ideas and practices in one way or another.
And we can see that even in how we do the,
the work on emotion.
So for example,
you know,
in a lot of the work we define positive emotion as high arousal positive states,
it just makes sense,
right?
The people who are putting together the inventories are coming from an American
context and um,
and are unconsciously,
you know,
defining states in a certain way that are a product of their culture.
And so I think we really need to try to rethink some of our assumptions about
emotion aspect of processes that take into consideration other cultural ideas
and practices.
I think that's how we're going to really understand really,
um,
all the ins and outs of the emotional life.
So that's where I,
I hope is going.
Um,
so birth interdisciplinarily and,
um,
and then I think in doing this work across cultures and taking into
consideration cultural ideas.
And practices,
I think we're going to be integrating even more across different levels of
analysis.
I think that's really exciting
and I love to,
the emphasis you're putting on context,
right?
That everyone comes from a different context.
And culture is one of the most profound context that we live in.
Right?
And we're conducting these studies many times acting as if people live in a
vacuum and that everyone lives in the same vacuum.
Right.
Wait.
Yeah.
And I think the real question is,
I mean the interesting thing about human emotion is how flexible it is and how
much it is shaped by our cultural context.
So I'm really hoping that's where we're going to go next.
I hope so too.
So then often I'm sure people come to you and ask you about the future of
emotion to our students,
or maybe just the general public getting interested in emotion and wanting to
learn more.
So when you do have students or people in general who come to you and ask you
for advice,
what do,
what do you tell them?
For those who are thinking about embarking in this exciting,
mysterious and like you're saying,
flexible world of emotion.
Well I think it's really exciting all of the tools that we're developing to
study different aspects of,
um,
the emotion process or different aspect of phenomena.
So I think it's important to learn as many tools as possible and to learn the
models.
But I also think it's important to think outside the box.
And so at the same time that you're mastering these different techniques and
mastering use different models to really be open to a variety of different
perspectives and to question,
you know,
are these really the emotions that we should be studying?
Are there other states that we could include in our studies that might reveal
other interesting things about our emotional lives?
So it's a combination of mastering existing tools and integrating them in new
and interesting ways,
but at the same time sort of questioning them and always sort of pushing the
envelope in terms of,
you know,
what we include in our studies.
That's probably what's going to future students of emotion.
Well,
I think it makes it a very exciting future.
Talking to you.
So many opportunities,
right.
And so many different levels to tackle it at and to try to also look at these
different levels simultaneously.
Yup,
exactly.
So thank you again for joining us today,
Jeanie.
This concludes our experts and emotion interview with Doctor Jeannie Sigh from
Stanford University.